after the technical problems we had a
hard time following your game at the end
so so could we please ask what happened
at the end here yeah i just i was
completely lost um
because i've just gave a check but he
blunders his queen in one move
which is very strange he normally
doesn't do this but yeah i guess it's my
luck today
are you happy with your play today
larassa yeah it was pretty good but this
last game was a very low level from me
he played very good but
in the opening i made a lot of mistakes
it's it's interesting what is happening
in the other games now because magnus
may lose to duda he's down two to one
tomorrow you play magnus how do you feel
about that game yes um i think it's
going to be very interesting he's in a
very good shape
he's um
he's losing today but bro maybe he
comebacks also nothing is clear but i
yeah i'm looking forward to the
match because it's always very
interesting to play against magnus but
how about you you're in pretty good
shape now too right yeah and i started
playing decently after the progs match
but uh
yeah i'm happy this might play until
here yeah
thank you this good luck tomorrow